[Musique]
annulé l'année dernière à cause du coc
vite 19 le salon international de
l'agriculture se tiendra cette année du
26 février au 6 mars plusieurs
producteurs yvelinois et seront présents
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
lauriane conseil et manon batista ont
été sélectionnés pour représenter l'île
de france lors de la finale nationale
des jeunes bergers au salon de
l'agriculture
les deux jeunes filles de 20 ans se
prépare aux épreuves théoriques et
pratiques élèves à la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet elles peuvent compter sur
les conseils de leur formatrice mardi 15
février au programme parage des onglons
tu suis la partie sombre de tomber ton
pied criage des brebis à l'aide d'un
lecteur électronique à cet âge ou sa
passion kit et ça va nous mais piqué et
appréciation de l'état de santé d'une
brebis devant on va regarder déjà sur
port comores
observations des dents des yeux des
pâtes tout y passe au niveau de ses
dents et dans la voir huit ont converti
a pas trop de ses actes et s'ils sont
pas trop écartées
si l on n'a pas perdu il faut qu entre
nos deux anglais que ça soit le plus
clair possible qui pas d'odeur lauriane
et manon seront face à 38 autres
participants venant de toute la france
très stressée vraiment stressé mais il
perd heureuse et
pédiatre mais en même temps elle très
perpignan bat un peu stressé mais plutôt
confiante parce que c'est la troisième
fois que je participe du coup j'ai envie
de vraiment prouver ce que je sais faire
avec pierre rencontré beaucoup de
professionnels du milieu comme elle l'a
dit ça peut être très très cool est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'on est confiant je
sais pas j'ai un stress de formatrice
derrière quand même mais mais je leur
fais confiance parce que
elles sont au taquet on se prépare donc
il n'y a pas de raison que ça ne fasse
pas cette finale nationale du meilleur
jeune berger permet également aux
participants de découvrir le métier de
l'intérieur grâce aux échanges avec les
professionnels dans les prochaines
années plus d'un éleveur sur 2 partira à
la retraite la filière ovine propose
près de 10000 emplois dans la prochaine
décennie
ce concours est donc l'occasion de
préparer la relève
[Musique]